u.s president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin are set to hold
talks on tuesday over rising tensions
between russia and ukraine the
announcement comes as large groups of
russian troops are reportedly gathering
at the border between the countries
raising concerns they could be preparing
to attack ukraine russia says it's
entitled to station its troops wherever
it wants and insists they pose no threat
focusing in
on what might lie ahead
these ukrainian soldiers are patiently
preparing for the worst here along what
many international experts say could
become the front lines of a full-scale
battle between russia and the ukraine
if russian troops attack us
we are ready to fight back
all of us are ready
in fact we've been waiting for this for
a long time
russia seized crimea from ukraine in
2014
sparking an ongoing war in the eastern
donbas region of ukraine bordering
russia
since the crimean peninsula was taken
moscow has backed separatists fighting
for control of the area
with the recent buildup of russian
forces on the border ukraine says it has
little choice but to prep for an attack
maybe they are just provoking us
maybe yes maybe no
nobody knows what our enemies are
thinking right now
because
the conflict has killed more than 13 000
people
including thousands of civilians
now residents feel they're being asked
to prepare for a full-out battle with
russia that's just too good what will
happen then
nothing good
it won't be the same kind of war as in
the past
they have nothing else to do but to
start a nuclear war with us
could ukraine lose the donbass region to
russia and if not how much further loss
of life could be necessary to ward off
the threat
international allies like the us and
others have voiced support but will that
be enough to protect ukraine or is
russia just flexing its muscles on the
borders again
looking to keep everyone guessing and
retaliation at bay
for more on this i'm joined by cardi
leek a senior policy fellow at the
european council on foreign relations in
berlin it's great to have you with us on
dw news how real is a threat of a
russian invasion of ukraine
i think it is real but not necessarily
imminent as i understand restroom
buildup
it is still first and foremost an
invitation to talk
but
the aim of race talks will be handing
moscow control over ukraine's future
political choices
which is very hard to do for anyone in
the west
not to mention immoral
and i think moscow means that they
seriously want to have a proper leverage
over ukraine
and they are prepared to achieve that by
military means if diplomacy given no
risk gives no results
well moscow has denied planning an
attack and also says it's entitled to
deploy troops wherever it wants so what
is putin's intention here
well i think putin's intention is the
same it has always been
he wants to exclude nato membership for
ukraine and have a firm leverage to make
sure that ukraine will never ever think
of anything like chris uh for several
years since 2015 moscow has hoped to
achieve
that goal by implementation of the minsk
agreements that imposed sort of
ceasefire and the active phase of war in
2015. however now they have probably
realized that the agreements are not
working as they hope
that ukraine even under presidency
lenski is not fulfilling the agreements
as moscow reads it
and at the same time they see that with
western military help ukraine is
becoming
a stronger and stronger
adversary even in military
means so
they simply want to put a stop on the
erosion of the leverage they had via the
minsk agreements and now they see it's
going away
now with these talks expected to come up
on tuesday how do you see president joe
biden uh taking these talks forward
it's a tricky one
because
by then
he has no intention to invite ukraine to
join nato but he's in no position to
declare the tall close to ukraine
forever after
so i do not think there is a good
solution to the situation that said
biden has very skillful diplomats i
think the us diplomacy right now
is is better than it has been for uh for
a long time
so
i guess that the creativity of freeze
people could come to some solutions but
i cannot properly think of
my advice would be to play for time try
to freeze the situation until moscow
comes to its senses and says that the
sort of control they want to have over
ukraine is impossible in principle not
because the west denies it but because
ukraine doesn't want it and
it is simply not doable in 21st century
the way it was possible after the cold
war after sorry after second world war
if things were to escalate and russia
was to invade ukraine
who would provide ukraine military
support who are its allies right now
well many nato countries have been
giving ukraine military support
not because they think of ukraine as a
future nato member but simply because
ukraine is a victim in that debate
i guess military aid could be supplied
in the future too but
it doesn't amount to boots on the ground
i think when it comes to actively
fighting the wall ukraine will be on its
own
okay cardi leak thank you very much for
your time and analysis